aber leute was ich noch mal nochmal
ansprechen wollte also es gibt wirklich
diesen trend auf instagram dass frauen
freiwillig ihre nippel zeigen dass kids
und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
folge micro fischplatte jolly mit dem
band of the team eine minecraft freuen
wollte ich gar nicht sagen nein
natürlich gerne hier ausgesucht und wir
haben sehr sehr sehr sehr viele themen
für heute unter anderem er wollte mich
überraschen er wollte mir so was
erzählen so eine story und dann an das
erzähl mir im video genau erklärt ich
wollte was was sagen aber da habe ich
gedacht ich mache jetzt ich sag's ihm
lieber im video damit ihr einfach so
erzählen wenn man auch schön cash damit
machen kann ich meine wir lassen den
überraschungseffekt für dich da dann ist
es tatsächlich kurios und zwar wenn ich
in letzter zeit bissen mehr auf
instagram unterwegs und kommerz anfang
an opa ein bisschen mehr auf instagram
unterwegs und hab da einen trend
entdeckt oder sagen wir mal eine
bewegung die ich absolut unterstützt so
finde ich richtig richtig gut
natürlich alles komplett uneigennützigen
gründen ich wollte einfach mal davon
erzählen dass du da bist aber zählt das
land darüber auch bescheid weiß und zwar
thema gleichberechtigung
es ist es kann einfach nicht sein
meiner meinung nach dass männer und
nicht nur meiner meinung nach dass
männer in der öffentlichkeit ihre
brustwarzen zeigen dürfen
aber frauen nicht
und ich sage es gibt auch instagram
einfach einen trend frauen die
bereitwillig und gerne und aus voller
überzeugung ihre nackten brüste
fotografieren
aus dem grund dass es das für sie ihre
auffassung von von feminismus
beziehungsweise von gleichberechtigung
der frau ist denn sie wollen ab jetzt
auch ihre nippel in der öffentlichkeit
so nipplegate oder so ich weiß nicht
aber es gibt da schon eine seit ich die
hatte zwar nach trost ich gesehen habe
aber auf dieser seite wandert echt baff
round 1 at the scale ich schaff das
nicht ich bin so scheiße wenn auch ein
paar nippel die mich auf weitere ja ich
kenne was instagram paula guck mal die
plastik ist verstimmt liebe das jetzt
nicht so die villa ihre nippel darf kein
vor
ich will ich würde echt gern mal wissen
wer von diesen drei kreaturen draußen
ich bin wenn ich vier games oder
schriften zeilen hast du bist du bist
der letzte treffer ich sauge die nutzer
vor glück gehabt als ich hier und man
halte diesen leiter sprung geschafft
easy peasy dem man toll
kein problem auf jeden fall leute ich
möchte mich an schöne frauen gewesen
ausgeliehen
wir müssen hier können wir die nippel
challenge was ist den vip zelt ja
natürlich nutze meine videos war
sicherlich eine besagt dass man jeden
satz einmal das lockmittel untergebracht
haben natürlich auf den gekonnten die
bilder gehen
overknees nicht runtergefallen schafft
das nicht ich schmeiße kreis die maus
hat und dann habe ich meine miete ich
manchmal den mittelwelle kann ich doch
schicken land sowie ein blendender dann
diese schönen auf den lippen von doktor
bayerns wäldern sehen wollt 1040 will
auch kraftvoll ab kacken aber eher als
wenn wir die prozent glauben dass alle
leute weiter das ist das nach ohne witz
meint das ist das schwierigste
jump'n'run das ich jemals gespielt habe
und das ist einfach ganz normal dass ich
das jetzt auch bei sich beim zweiten
partition gar nicht weiterkommt er ist
und die anderen haben ausnahmslos flex
an
wie nutze ich das werde ich jetzt
einfach weiter darüber habe ich auch
schon mal nachgedacht beim thema war wie
hart geil und zeitgleich asozial aber
auch skandalträchtiges wäre wenn du
einfach in war keine ahnung ungespielt
angreifst aber mit hex ich finde dass
das du dass der glaube ich kacke aber
kleidung aber das ist okay was ich mega
feiern würde
wer einfach irgendwie so ein flyer heck
dass er dann einfach so es geht los und
du fliegst über die leute drüber oder
sollte das eher weniger lustig dass das
ich wird das feiern
da würde ich ihn darauf geben ganz
ehrlich glaube ich werde dir ins
weggeschmissen werden aber ich werde
wahrscheinlich schnappatmung kriegen
das war so witzig aber zurück zum thema
instagram habe noch nicht gesagt und
jemand nippel zurück ich hab zwar im
thema nippel ich habe tatsächlich drei
häuser sind max hat mehreren apple aber
dass das hat er nicht von mir keine
admin einem lippe ein halber mensch die
andere anderen apple masse sein kern
gewandert und hat eine ganz schnelle
veränderung ausgelassen das auto ich
durchaus auch im trend das mein letzter
beim organspendeausweis doch die lippe
noch mit an tragen kann
weil die sind hat auch gefragt was ist
los mit apple wieder mich bist jetzt
wird geflickt game sie sind einfach
älter werde gibt zwei drei mal mehr die
wp pro gamer ist als du hier sein wirst
wenn wir die gestalter ist nun fix sei
sollte toni ich bin so schlecht wie
gegen dieser sprung man richtig trägt
750 als keiner aber dieser sprung ist
wirklich schwer
ich würde gerne weiterhin gar nicht so
scheiße naja ich bin schon scheiße ich
weiß halt die chance hat verschiedene
schattierungen und abstufung
das lassen sie bei abstufen sind in
sachen die schattierung noch gern mache
ich die ganze zeit und sprung faltig
kennt das gebiet auch gar nicht [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] war verkackt ich hab' ich
hab's erneut alter wenn ich jetzt den
checkpoint ich schaffe das know how was
ehrlich jetzt bis abgekriegt jährlich
jetzt meiner den verdammte zweite goalie
schild aus schritt der ein brot das ist
mein gesamtes essen ja dass nico der
tagen ist indes klar wie man den wald
hineinruft
so hatten die us schwert was der mich
geholt hat krasser gut alter aber leute
was ich nochmal und nochmal ansprechen
wollte also es gibt wirklich diesen
trend auf instagram dass frauen
freiwillig ihre nippel zeigen und das
auch noch für ein politisches statement
halten was ich natürlich aus rein
uneigennützigen unterstütze und diese
seiten sind aber noch nicht so beliebt
ich habe zumindest ist ja nur eine
gesehen hatte 800 follower oder so
die machen ein sternchen gebärende
bürger sorgt die frauen wollen das
zeigen die wollen das zeigen und regen
sich darüber auf dass sie ihre nippel
nicht zeigen dürfen im internet ja es
nicht weil ich mein manche leute haben
keinen kann kein erster zum trinken aber
andere leute und wollen ihre lippe
zeigen wer bin ich dass ich das in frage
stelle nico jetzt bist du dran nico herr
jetzt kassiert hatte eine kiste
ich höre ich hätte
ich beneide jedoch ja ja ich bin musste
ich pass mal auf du bist du okay peace
wieder für dich antis gebracht
das wollte ich doch verschonen team aber
1000 euro
ich komme hier nicht raus leute von
leichen
wenn dir die eine milliarde leicht
schaffen blende ich euch am ende den
namen der fällt der instagram seite ein
optiker diese diese nippel aktivisten
wir über gutachten können vielleicht
macht es echt mal muss man schauen wie
lustig in der nachbearbeitung sind ich
bin ich bin ja ein gespräch und gleich
verdammt lustigsten tempo vor
wie war das mit ihr über das motiv
wie was es mit diesen ganzen fakt ist
andre linken das findet das ist
erschwert
der grip war der schlag hinzu mir dann
steht fest wer stellt audi hat sich
beobachtet kommt raus da kommt noch
einer
er kommt zu mir kommen wir nicht raus
ich bin ein gesperrt nachrodt
aber ich habe ihnen locker dreimal gilt
aber der müsste jetzt so sein dann
kriegst junge wie viel leben der harte
alltag vor allem wie kommt ihr schaffen
leute wie kann der ansgar schwenken
hexen gibt zitiert haben längst oder
hacks schreibt sie die kommentare jetzt
habe ich noch nie gelaufen
ich sag nix leute waren sex oder man sex
schreibt sie die kommentare und
eventuell dürft ihr kind ist ein video
ad punkt punkt punkt gesehen haben wenn
es in der beschreibung verlinkt wie es
im nächsten video wieder allein macht's
gut